‏Please double check yourones. Make sure
that they are silent.
And whoever is hearing that little
whisper right now that my phone's not
going to ring. He's not talking to me.
It's exactly you that I'm talking to.
Please check yourone. Make sure that it
is silent. We don't want to hear about
it. We want to have some silent time
with our Lord. We only get about an hour
and a half here with him.
اوكي
استووا واعتدلوا
الله اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
سيقول السفهاء
من الناس ما ولاهم عن قبلتهم التي كانوا
عليها
قل لله المشرق والمغرب يهدي من يشاء
الى صراط مستقيم
وكذلك جعلناكم امه
وسطا
لتكونوا شهداء
على الناس ويكون الرسول عليكم شهيدا
وما جعلنا القبله التي كنت عليها الا
لنعلم من يتبع الرسول رسول
الا لنعلم من يتبع الرسول ممن ينقلب على
عقبيه
وان كانت لكبيره
الا على الذين هدى الله
وما كان الله ليضيع ايمانكم
ان الله بالناس لرؤوف رحيم
قد نرى تقلب وجهك في السماء
فلنوليك
قبله ترضاها
فول وجهك شطر المسجد الحرام
وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم شطره
وان الذين اوتوا الكتاب ليعلمون انه الحق
من ربهم
وما الله بغافل عما يعملون
ولئن اتيت الذين اوتوا الكتاب بكل ايه ما
تبعوا قبلتك وما انت بتابع
قبلتهم
وما بعضهم بتابع
قبله بعض ولائن ان اتبعت اهواءهم
من بعد ما جاءك من العلم انك اذا لمن
الظالمين
الذين اتيناهم الكتاب يعرفونه كما يعرفون
ابناءهم
وان فريقا منهم ليكتمون الحق وهم يعلمون
الحق من ربك فلا تكونن
من الممترين
ولكل وجهه هو موليها
فاستبقوا الخيرات
اينما تكونوا يات بكم الله جميعا
ان الله على كل شيء قدير
ومن حيث خرجت فول وجهك شطر المسجد الحرام
وانه للحق من ربك وما الله بغافل عما
تعملون
ومن حيث خرجت فول وجهك شطر المسجد الحرام
وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم شطره
فولوا وجوهكم شطره لان يكون للناس عليكم
حجه الا الذين ظلموا منهم فلا تخشوهم
واخشوني
ولاتم نعمتي عليكم ولعلكم تهتدون
كما ارسلنا فيكم رسولا منكم يتل
عليكم اياتنا ويزكيكم
ويزكيكم ويعلمكم
الكتاب والحكمه
ويعلمكم
ما لم تكونوا تعلمون
فاذكروني اذكركم واشكروا لي ولا تكفرون
يا ايها الذين امنوا استعينوا بالصبر والص
صلاه
ان الله مع الصابرين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سبحان ربي
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا استعينوا بالصبر والص
صلاه
ان الله مع الصابرين
ولا تقولوا لمن يقتل في سبيل الله اموات
بل احياء
ولكن لا تشعرون
ولنبلونكم
بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص من الاموال
والانفس والثمرات
وبشر الصابرين
الذين اذا اصابتهم
مصيبه
قالوا
قالوا انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون
اولئك
عليهم صلوات من ربهم ورحمه واولئك
هم المهتدون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبرلام
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم خير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله رب العالمين
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم خير
الضالين
الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر
আসসালামু আলাইকুম
জাস্ট ওরিার
make
parle
can you pleas take minut and take out
there be
ইশনে
ইমপন্ এ আলহামদুলিল্লাহ
অফার এন্ড unফচুরা
কলেজ ভেরি মাচ ফতার
অ000
000ப
[Silence]
ت000
make
‏people look for
ch
and sister and the so
500 br sister to their to off one
day of there
تكبير
[Silence]
‏I want to than you very much sor to b
you kind of requ but just you want to
make somebody
to do what can the mon of
تكبير
يلا الحمد لله ما شاء الله
تكبير ما شاء الله تكبير
as you can
dr not
‏just take care of we just do not like
theend look and you know just not
comforable so make comm
now until the day of
so
back000
upar
notempty
‏If you did full day you put your name
in that in one of the spots if half a
day just put a half next to it. If you
do 500 put a one quarter next to it.
Pick up any slot put your name number
and put one quarter next to it.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
من فطر صائما فله مثل اجره لا ينقص من
اجره شيئا
feeds
a personat
from
you will get the reward of the day of
fast that they
‏entirely and they will get the reward
for it. So if you have 10 people
breaking fast on your food you just fast
10 days.
‏If 20
200 people broke their fast and you got
all that because we generous god however
thanks سبحانه وتالى بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد
ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اخي اسامه
اوكي
امام البخاري امام مسلم
سعد الساعدي رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان في الجنه بابا
يقال له الريان
لا يدخل منه الا الصائمون يوم القيامه
يقال اين الصائمون
فيقومون فيدخلون منه لا يدخل منه احد
غيرهم ثم يغلق فلا يدخل
منه احد سواهم او كما قال صلى الله عليه
‏parad
gates parad
gates
to
excellence
a particular type of excellent people
brothers and sisters who will be invited
‏those obedience of their par those fing
those knowledge andad which is a tye
ofad
each one of the doors of parad has a
designated tye of person that they will
be enter they will be invited to enter
[Silence]
انسو الريان على وزن الفعلان مثل الرحمن
مثل الرحمن للدلاله على الامتلاء والسع
‏name
parad
the great
of
the great quencher of that is for the
people of fast those who excellent at
fing theinent difficulty
‏would any
of parad is greatent of the end
of thirst quenching meaning that anyone
who enters through that gate will never
experience thirst again not even in
theirination
they will thly
صلى الله عليه وسلم
where
‏and will
no will be permitt to enter with them
through it and it will be closed and no
one else will ever be able to enter
through that gate but them this is
in for why does the propet tell us this
in
he tells us this so that we have a go
and ‏someinant
go
and
no i have my eyes on particular gate to
that i head for that gate
i going to make
not
without my name being add to the list of
gu that will enter through that gate
ضان
الله تعالى نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمني
وكرمي وجوده ان يتقبل منا صيامنا وقيامنا
وان يجعل نصيبنا من الصيام الجوع وان يجعل
نصيبنا من القيام الا السهر
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعلنا جميعا من
الصائمين الذين ينفذون من باب الريان يوم
القيامه والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وان شاء الله
صلاه
حفاظ جزاكم الله
شيخ
عاصم
‏have
been wed
veteran at this point my paring spot out
there is all the way next to the thing
next to the two spots right beside mine
those are going to be for our insall
[Silence]
صلاه
ان شاء الله جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
في شقاق بعيد يا
استووادوا
حاذين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
‏take
your
other
الله اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الصفا والمروه من شعائر
الله
فمن حج البيت او اعتمر فلا جناح عليه ان
يطوف بهما
ومن تطوع خيرا فان الله شاكر عليم
ان الذين يكتب ون ما انزلنا من البينات
والهدى من بعد ما بيناه للناس
من بعد ما بيناه للناس في الكتاب اولئك
يلعنهم الله
اولئك
يلعنهم الله ويلعنهم اللاعنون
الا الذين تابوا واصلحوا وبينوا فاولئك
اتوب عليهم
فاولئك
اتوب عليهم وانا التواب الرحيم
ان الذين كفروا وماتوا وهم كفار اولئك
عليهم لعنه الله والملائكه
والناس اجمعين
خالدين فيها لا يخفف عنهم العذاب ولا هم
ينظرون
والهكم اله واحد لا اله الا هو الرحمن
الرحيم
ان في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف الليل
والنهار والفلك التي تجري في البحر بما
ينفع
الناس
وما انزل الله من السماء من ماء
فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها
فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها وبث فيها من كل
دابه
وتصريف الرياح وتصريف الرياح
والسحاب المسخر بين السماء
والارض لايات لقوم يعقلون
ومن الناس من يتخذ من دون الله اندادا
يحبونهم كحب الله
والذين امنوا اشد حبا لله
ولو يرى الذين ظلموا اذ يرون العذاب ان
القوه لله جميعا وان الله
وان الله شديد العذاب
اذ تبرا الذين اتبعوا من الذين اتبعوا
وراوا العذاب وتقطعت بهم الاسباب
وقال الذين اتبعوا لو ان لنا كره
فنتبرا منهم كما تبراوا منا
كذلك يريهم الله اعمالهم حسرات عليهم
وما هم بخارجين من النار
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض ضالين
امين
يا ايها الناس كلوا مما في الارض حلالا
طيبا ولا تتبعوا خطوات الشيطان
ولا تتبعوا خطوات شيطان انه لكم عدو مبين
انما يامركم بالسوء
والفحشاء
وان تقولوا على الله ما لا تعلمون
واذا قيل لهم اتبعوا ما انزل الله قالوا
بل نتبع ما الفينا عليه اباءنا
اولو كان اباؤهم
لا يعقلون شيئا ولا يهتدون
ومثل الذين كفروا كمثل الذي ينعق بما لا
يسمع الا دعاء
ونداء
صم بكم علي فهم لا يعقلون
يا ايها الذين امنوا كلوا من طيبات ما
رزقناكم
واشكروا لله ان كنتم اياه تعبدون
انما حرم عليكم الميته والدم ولحم الخنزير
وما اهل به لغير الله
فمن اضطر غير باغ
ولا عاد فلا اثم عليه
ان الله غفور رحيم
ان الذين يكتمون ما انزل الله من الكتاب
ويشترون به ثمنا قليلا اولئك
اولئك
ما ياكلون في بطونهم الا النار
ولا يكلمهم الله يوم القيامه ولا يزكيهم
ولهم عذاب اليم
ذلك بان
اولئك
الذين اشتروا الضلاله بالهدى والعذاب
بالمغفره
فمن من اصبرهم على النار
ذلك بان الله نزل الكتاب بالحق
وان الذين
وان الذين اختلفوا في الكتاب لفي شقاق
بعيد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه اللهح
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلستو
سو الصاب سد الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ليس البر ان تولوا وجوهكم قبل المشرق
والمغرب
ولكن البر من امن بالله واليوم الاخر
والملائكه
والكتاب والنبيين
واتى المال على حبه ذوي القربى واليتامى
والمساكين وابن السبيل
والمساكين وابن السبيل والسا سائلين
وفي الرقاب واقام الصلاه واتى الزكاه
والموفون بعهدهم اذا عاهدوا
والصابرين في الباساء
والضراء
وحين الباس اولئك الذين صدقوا واولئك هم
المتقون
يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم القصاص في
القتلى
الحر بالحر والعبد بالعبد والانثى بالانثى
فمن عفي له من اخيه شيء فاتباع
بالمعروف واداء اليه باحسان
ذلك تخفيف
من ربكم ورحمه
فمن اعتدى بعد ذلك فله عذاب اليم
ولكم في القصاص حياه يا اولي الالباب
لعلكم تتقون
كتب عليكم اذا حضر احدكم كتب عليكم اذا
حضر احدكم الموت ان ترك خيرا الوصيه
الوصيه للوالدين والاقربين بالمعروف حقا
على المتقين
فمن بدله بعد ما سمعه فانما اثمه على
الذين يبدلونه
ان الله سميع عليم
فمن خاف من موص جنفا او اثما فاصلح بينهم
فلا اثم عليه
ان الله غفور رحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم الصيام كما
كتب على الذين من قبلكم
لعلكم تتقون
اياما
معدودات
فمن كان منكم مريضا او على سفر فعده من
ايام اخر
وعلى الذين يطيقونه فديه طعام مسكين
فمن تطوع خيرا فهو خير له وان تصوموا خير
لكم ان كنتم تعلم
ون
شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران هدى للناس
وبينات من الهدى والفرقان
فمن شهد منكم الشهر فليصمه
ومن كان مريضا او على سفر فعده
ومن كان مريضا او على سفر فعده من ايام
اخر يريد الله بكم اليسر ولا يريد بكم
العسر ولتكملوا العده ولتكبروا الله على
ما هداكم
ولعلكم تشكرون
واذا سالك عبادي عني فاني قريب
فاني قريب اجيب دعوه الداعي اذا دعان
فليستجيبوا
لي وليؤمنوا بي لعلهم يرشدون
احل لكم ليله الصيام الرفث الى نسائكم
هن لباس لكم وانتم لباس لهم
علم الله انكم كنتم تختانون انفسكم فتاب
عليكم
فتاب عليكم وعفى عنكم
فالان باشروهن
وابتغوا ما كتب الله لكم وكلوا واشربوا
حتى يتبين لكم الخيط الابيض من الخيط
الاسود
وكلوا واشربوا حتى يتبين لكم الخيط الابيض
من الخيط الاسود من الفجر ولا تباشروهن
وانتم عاكفون في المساجد
ثم تموا الصيام الى الليل
ولا تباشروهن
وانتم
عاكفون في المساجد
تلك حدود الله فلا تقربوها
كذلك يبين الله اياته للناس لعلهم يتقون
ولا تاكلوا اموالكم
بينكم بالباطل وتدلوا بها الى الحكام
لتاكلوا
لتاكلوا فريق قا من اموال الناس بالاثم
وانتم
تعلمون
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
يسالونك عن الاهله قل هي مواقيت للناس
والحج
وليس البر وليس البر بان تاتوا البيوت من
ظهورها لكن البر من اتقى
واتوا البيوت من ابوابها واتقوا الله
لعلكم تفلحون
وقاتلوا في سبيل الله الذين يقاتلونكم
ولا تعتدوا
ان الله لا يحب المعتدين
واقتلوهم حيث ثقفتموهم واخرجوهم
من حيث اخرجوكم
والفتنه اشد من القتل ولا تقاتلوهم عند
المسجد الحرام حتى يقاتلوكم فيه
فان قاتلوكم فاقتلوهم كذلك جزاء الكافرين
فانوا
فان الله غفور رحيم
وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون فتنه ويكون الدين
لله
فانوا فلا عدوان الا على الظالمين
الشهر الحرام بالشهر الحرام والحرمات قصاص
فمن اعتدى عليكم فاعتدوا عليه بمثل ما
اعتدى عليكم
واتقوا اقوا الله واعلموا ان الله مع
المتقين
وانفقوا
وانفقوا في سبيل الله ولا توقوا بايديكم
الى التهلكه واحسنوه
ان الله يحب المحسنين
واتموا الحج والعمره لله فان احصرتم فما
استيسر من الهدي
ولا تحلقوا رؤوسكم حتى يبلغ الهدي محله
فمن كان منكم مريضا او به اذى من راسه
ففديه
ففديه من صيام او صدقه او نسك فاذا امنتم
فمن تمتع بالعمره الى الحج فما استيسر من
الهدي
فمن لم يجد فصيام ثلاثه ايام في الحج
وسبعه اذا رجعتم
تلك عشره كامله ذلك لمن لم يكن اهله حاضر
المسجد الحرام
واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله شديد العقاب
الحج اشهر معلومات مات فمن فرض فيهن الحج
فلا رفث ولا فسوق ولا جدال في الحج وما
تفعلوا من خير يعلمه الله
وتزودوا فان خير الزاد التقوى واتقوني يا
اولي الالباب
ليس عليكم جناح ان تبتغوا فضل فضلا من
ربكم
فاذا فضتم من عرفات فاذكروا الله عند
المشعر الحرام
واذكروه كما هداكم وان كنتم من قبله لمن
الضالين
ثم
فيضوا من حيث افاض الناس واستغفروا الله
واستغفروا الله ان الله غفور رحيم
فاذا قضيتم مناسككم فاذكروا الله كذكركم
اباءكم
او اشد ذكرا
فمن الناس من يقول ربنا اتنا في الدنيا
وما له في الاخره من خلاق
ومنهم من يقول ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه
وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار
اولئك
لهم نصيب مما كسبوا
والله سريع الحساب
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استووا اعتديلهذا
استووا
لا
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
واذكروا الله في ايام معدودات
فمن تعجل في يومين فلا اثم عليه ومن تاخر
فلا اثم عليه لمن اتقى واتقوا الله
واعلموا انكم اليه تحشرون
ومن الناس من يعجبك قوله في الحياه الدنيا
ويشهد الله على ما في قلبه وهو الد الخصام
واذا تولى سعى في الارض ليفسد فيها ويهلك
الحرث والنسل
والله لا يحب الفساد
واذا قيل له اتق الله اخذته العزه
بالاثم فحسبه جهنم
ولبئس المهاد
ومن الناس من يشري نفسه ابتغاء
مرضاه الله
والله رؤوف بالعباد
يا ايها الذين امنوا ادخلوا في السلم كافه
ولا تتبعوا خطوات
الشيطان
انه لكم عدو مبين
فان زللتم من بعد ما جاءتكم
البينات فاعلموا ان الله عزيز حكيم
هل ينظرون الا ان ياتيهم الله في ظل من
الغمام والملائكه
وقضي
الامر والى الله ترجع الامور
سلبني اسرائيل كم اتيناهم من ايه بينه ومن
يبدل نعمه الله من بعد ما جاءته
فان الله شديد العقاب
زين للذين كفروا الحياه الدنيا ويسخرون من
الذين امنوا والذين اتقوا فوقهم يوم
القيامه
والله يرزق من يشاء
بغير حساب
كان الناس امه واحده فبعث الله النبيين
مبشرين ومنذرين
وانزل معهم الكتاب بالحق ليحكم بين الناس
فيما اختلفوا فيه
وما اختلف فيه الا الذين اوتوه من بعد ما
جاءتهم
البينات بغيا بينهم
فهدى الله الذين امنوا لما اختلفوا فيه من
الحق باذنه
والله يهدي من يشاء
الى صراط مستقيم
والله يهدي من يشاء الى صراط مستقيم
ام حسبتم ان تدخلوا الجنه ولما ياتكم مثل
الذين خلوا من قبلكم
مستهم الباساء
والضراء
وزلزلوا
وزلزلوا حتى يقول الرسول والذين امنوا معه
متى نصر الله
الا ان نصر الله قريب
يسالونك ماذا ينفقون
قل ما انفقتم من خير فللوالدين والاقربين
واليتامى والمساكين وابن السبيل
وما تفعلوا من خير فان الله به عليم.
كتب عليكم القتال وهو كره لكم
وعسى ان تكرهوا شيئا وهو خير لكم وعسى ان
تحبوا شيئا وهو شر لكم والله يعلم وانتم
لا تعلمون
يسالونك عن الشهر الحرام قتال فيه قل قتال
كبير
وصد عن سبيل الله وكفر به والمسجد الحرام
واخراج اهله منه اكبر عند الله
والفتنه اكبر من القتل
ولا يزالون يقاتلونكم حتى يردوكم عن دينكم
ان استطاعوا
ومن يرتد منكم عن دينه فيمت وهو كافر
فاولئك
حبطت اعمالهم
حبطت اعمالهم في الدنيا والاخره واولئك
هم الخاسرون
[Arabic recitation]
واولئك
اصحاب النار هم فيها خالدون
ان الذين امنوا والذين هاجروا وجاهدوا في
سبيل الله
سبيل الله اولئك
يرجون رحمه الله
والله غفور
رحيم
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
يسالونك عن الخمر والميسر قل فيهما اثم
كبير ومنافع للناس واثمهما اكبر من نفعهما
ويسالونك ماذا ينفقون قل العفو كذلك يبين
الله
الايات لعلكم تتفكرون
في الدنيا والاخره
ويسالونك عن اليتامى قل اصلاح لهم خير وان
تخالطوهم فاخوانكم
والله يعلم المفسد من المصلح ولو شاء الله
لاعنتكم ان الله عزيز حكيم
ولا تنكحوا المشركات حتى يؤمن
ولام مؤمنه خير من مشركه ولو اعجبتكم
ولا تنكحوا المشركين حتى يؤمنوا
ولعبد مؤمن خير من مشرك ولو اعجبكم
اولئك يدعون الى النار والله يدعو الى
الجنه والمغفره باذنه ويبين اياته للناس
لعلهم يتذكرون
ويسالونك عن المحيض قل هو اذى فاعتزلوا
النساء
في المحيض ولا تقربوهن
حتى يطهر
فاذا تطهرن فاتوهن من حيث امركم الله
ان الله يحب التوابين ويحب المتطهرين
نساؤكم حرث لكم فاتوا حرثكم انا شئتم
وقدموا لانفسكم
واتقوا الله واعلموا انكم ملاقوه
وبشر المؤمنين
ولا تجعل اجعلوا الله عرضه لايمانكم ان
تضروا وتتقوا وتصلحوا بين الناس
والله سميع عليم لا يؤاخذكم الله باللغو
في ايمانكم ولكن يؤاخذكم بما كسبت قلوبكم
والله غفور حليم
للذين يؤلون من نسائهم
تربص اربعه اشهر فان فاءوا فان الله غفور
رحيم وان عزموا الطلاق فان الله سميع عليم
والمطلقات يتربصن بانفسهن
ثلاثه قروء
ولا يحل لهن ان يكتن ما خلق الله في
ارحامهن
ان كن يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر
وبعولتهن
احق بردهن في ذلك ان ارادوا اصلاحا
ولهن مثل الذي عليهن بالمعروف
وللرجال عليهن
درجه والله عزيز حكيم
الطلاق مرتان فامساك بمعروف او تسريح
باحسان
ولا يحل لكم ان تاخذوا مما اتيتموهن
شيئا الا ان يخافا الا يقيما حدود الله
فان خفتم الا يقيما حدود الله فلا جناح
عليهما فيما افتدت به تلك حدود الله فلا
تعتدوها
ومن يتعدى حدود الله فاولئك
هم الظالمون
فان طلقها فلا تحل له من بعد حتى تنكح
زوجا غيره فان طلقها فلا جناح عليهما ان
يتراجعا ان ظنا ان يقيما حدود الله
وتلك حدود الله يبينها لقوم
يعلمون
واذا طلقتم النساء فبلغن اجلهن فامسكوهن
بمعروف او سرحوهن
بمعروف
ولا تمسكوهن
ضرارا لتع اعتدوا
ومن يفعل ذلك فقد ظلم نفسه ولا تتخذوا
ايات الله هزوا
واذكروا نعمه الله عليكم وما انزل عليكم
من الكتاب والحكمه يعظكم به واتقوا الله
واعلموا ان الله بكل شيء عليم
اذا طلقتم النساء فبلغن اجلهن فلا تعضلوهن
ان ينكحن ازواجهن
فلا تعطلوهن ان ينكحن ازواجهن اذا تراضوا
بينهم بالمعروف
ذلك يوعظ به من كان منكم يؤمن بالله
واليوم الاخر
ذلكم ازكى لكم واطهر
والله يعلم وانتم لا تعلمون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
اللهم صل على
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
انت بتشربوا من بعض
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب وب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والوالدات يرضعن اولادهن حولين كاملين لمن
اراد ان يتم الرضاعه
وعلى المولود له رزقهن وكسوتهن
بالمعروف
لا تكلف نفس الا وسعها
لا تضار
والده بولدها ولا مولود له بولده
وعلى الوارث مثل ذلك فان ارادا فصالا عن
تراض منهما وتشاور فلا جناح عليهما
وان اردتم ان تسترضعوا اولا دكم فلا جناح
عليكم اذا سلمتم ما اتيتم بالمعروف
واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله بما تعملون
بصير
والذين يتوفون منكم ويذرون ازواجا
يتربصن بانفسهن
اربعه اشهر وعشرا
فاذا بلغن اجلهن فلا جناح عليكم فيما فعلن
في انفسهن
بالمعروف
والله بما تعملون خبير
ولا جناح عليكم فيما عرضتم به من خطبه
النساء
او اكمنتم في انفسكم
علم الله انكم ستذكرونهن
لكن لا تواعدوهن
سرا الا ان تقولوا قولا معروفا
ولا تعزموا عقده النكاح حتى يبلغ الكتاب
اجله واعلموا ان الله يعلم ما في انفسكم
فاحذروه
واعلموا ان الله غفور حليم
لا جناح عليكم ان طلقتم النساء ما لم
تمسوهن او تفردوا لهن فريضه
ومتعوهن
على الموسع قدره وعلى المقتر قدره متاعا
بالمعروف
حقا على المحسنين
وان طلقتموهن
من قبل ان تمسوهن
وقد فرضتم لهن فريضه
فنصف ما فرضتم الا ان يعفون او يعفو الذي
بيده عقده النكاح
وان تعفوا اقرب للتقوى
ولا تنسوا
الفضل بينكم
ان الله بما تعملون بصير
حافظوا على الصلوات والصلاه الوسطى وقوموا
لله قانتين
فان خفتم فرجالا او ركبانا
فاذا امنتم فاذكروا الله كما علمكم ما لم
تكونوا تعلمون
والذين يتوفون منكم ويذرون ازواجا وصيه
لازواجهم
متاعا الى الحول غير اخراج
فان خرجن فلا جناح عليكم فيما فعلن في
انفسهن
من معروف
والله عزيز حكيم
وللمطلقات متاع بالمعروف حقا على المتقين
كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته لعلكم تعقلون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
لا اله الا انت سبحان
الم تر الى الذين خرجوا من ديارهم وهم
الوفر الموت فقال لهم الله موتوا ثم
احياهم
ان الله لذو فضل على الناس ولكن
اكثر الناس لا يشكرون
وقاتلوا في سبيل الله واعلموا ان الله
سميع عليم
من ذا الذي يقرض الله قرضا حسنا فيضاعفه
له اضعافا كثيره
والله يقبض ويبسط واليه ترجعون
الم تر الى الملا من بني اسرائيل
من بعد موسى اذ قالوا لنبي لهم ابعث لنا
ملكا نقاتل في سبيل الله
قال هل عسيتم ان كتب عليكم القتال الا
تقاتلوا
قالوا وما لنا الا نقاتل في سبيل الله وقد
اخرجنا من ديارنا وابنائنا
فلما كتب عليهم القتال تولوا الا قليلا
منهم والله عليم بالظالمين
وقال لهم نبيهم ان الله قد بعث لكم طالوت
ملكا
قالوا انا يكون له الملك علينا ونحن احق
بالملك منه ولم يؤت سعه من المال
قال ان الله اصطفاه عليكم وزاده بسطه في
العلم والجسم
والله يؤتي ملك
من يشاء
والله واسع عليم
وقال لهم نبيهم ان ايه ملكه ان ياتيكم
التابوت فيه سكينه من ربكم وبقيه
وبقيه مما ترك ال موسى وال هارون تحمله
الملا ملائكه
ان في ذلك لايه لكم ان كنتم مؤمنين
فلما فصل طالوت بالجنود قال ان الله
مبتليكم
بنهر فمن شرب منه فليس مني ومن لم يطعمه
فانه مني الا من اغترف غرفه بيد يده
فشربوا منه الا قليلا منهم فلما جاوزه هو
والذين امنوا معه قالوا لا طاقه لنا اليوم
بجالوت وجنوده
قال الذين يظنون انهم ملاقوا الله كم من
فئه قليله غلبت فئه كثيره باذن الله
والله مع الصابرين
ولما برزوا لجالوت وجنوده قالوا ربنا افرغ
علينا صدرا وثبت اقدامنا
قالوا ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا وثبت اقدامنا
وانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
فهزموهم باذن الله وقتل داوود جالوت واتاه
الله الملك والحكمه وعلمه مما يشاء
ولولا دفع الله الناس بعضهم ببعض لفسدت
الارض ولكن الله ذو فضل على العالمين
تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك بالحق
وانك لمن المرسلين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ان شاء
ممكن
اللي هو سبحان الله
يجزيك الخير
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي
قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى
فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل يا ايها الكافرون
لا اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا عابد ما
عبدتم
ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد لكم دينكم ولي
دين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
اشهد ان لا اله الا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
صلاه الوتر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك اللهم لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل
من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
نستغفرك اللهم من كل ذنب وخطيئه ونتوب
اليك
ونؤمن بك ونتوكل عليك ونكل كل اليك الامر
كله
ونكل اليك الامر كله
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك
ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك ومن اليقين
ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا
ابدا ما ابقيتنا
واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على من
ظلمنا
وانصرنا على من عادانا
ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا
ولا تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا
ولا تجعل الى النار مصيرنا
واجعل اللهم الجنه هي دارنا وقرارنا
برحمتك يا رب العالمين.
رب اغفر وارحم واعف وتكرم وتجاوز عما تعلم
انك تعلم ما لا نعلم انك انت الله الاعز
الاكرم اللهم اغفر لنا الذنوب واستر منا
العيوب وتب علينا يا مولانا كي نتوب اللهم
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا كلها دقها وجلها اولها
واخرها
على نيتها وسرها ما علمنا منها وما لم
نعلم برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين
اللهم اكتب لنا صيام شهر رمضان واكتب لنا
اجر قيام ليل رمضان اللهم اجعلنا من اهل
صيامه وقيامه واغفر لنا ذنوبنا كلها اللهم
اغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرنا وما اسررنا
وما اعلمنا وما انت اعلم به منا انت
المقدم وانت المؤخر ولا اله الا انت ربنا
اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا
عذاب النار وادخلنا الجنه مع الابرار يا
عزيز يا غفار يا ارحم الراحمين
اللهم توفنا مسلمين والحق قنا بالصالحين
ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا وذرياتنا قره اعين
واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب العالمين وصل
اللهم وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]